salut comment ça va regarder aujourd'hui
je vous parle de deux nouveaux
smartphones qui a sorti la marque pour
qotsa la regarder vous les avez là vous
avez juste en hausse et le poke au x 4
gt et en bas c'est le poke au f4 c'est
aujourd'hui une vidéo qui est réalisé en
partenariat avec poco poco commodité un
bon bougre eu à peu près avec ces mots
là est ce que tu voudrais pas présentés
nous deux nouveaux smartphones de
nouveau smartphone haut de gamme mais
avec un tarif milieu de gamme super
intéressant et c'est souvent ce que nous
propose pourquoi je sais pas si vous
connaissez pourquoi je ne sais pas si
vous avez déjà eu un smartphone de poko
d'ailleurs marqué le mois juste en
barrant commentaires si vous avez déjà
eu un smartphone de poko dites moi
quelle référence ct et est ce que vous
en avez été satisfait aux huit noms
claquement pour vous leur faire très
très très court pour course est une
marque là vous proposer des smartphones
à des tarifs milieu de gamme avec des
grosses performances avec des gros
processeur et beaucoup de puissance
pourquoi pour avoir de la fluidité pour
toutes les expériences de gaming pour
vous avez un truc qui marche bien qui ne
rame jamais et si vous aimez jouer
franchement vous allez satisfait et
c'est un peu ce qu'on me retrouver avec
ses deux nouveaux smartphones à savoir
le coco x4 j'étais celui là la beauté la
voyez comme il est mignon on retrouve
les couleurs jaune dans le proco
toujours la même idée et puis on a
également le poke au f4 alors les deux
racontent une histoire un petit peu
différente et des choix qui ont été
faits au niveau du processeur on évolue
taux de rafraîchissement niveau de pas
mal de choses on va regarder ça on va ce
détail et c'est donc aujourd'hui une
vidéo où on vient présenter ses deux
nouveaux smartphones et puis bien
évidemment je compte sur vous pour dire
ce que vous en pensez juste en ajustant
bas en commentaire oliva 1 c'est parti
alors c'est un tour du propriétaire
c'est un peu le bazar c'est deux
médecins un petit peu en forme un petit
tour du propriétaire j'ai même les
décrire mon fils je sais pas pourquoi
j'étais à écrire mon fils qui est là me
jette un crayon et un peu pété avoir
peut-être falloir rien nationaux et
autres écrits ou peu importe regardez on
va commencer par celui là regardez ça
celui là c'est le x4 alors luxe 4 ils
sont sympas tous les deux un franchement
beaucoup savent trés trés bien faire des
smartphones regarder le design a dû x
cap j'étais bien évidemment des gens il
va marquer ici poko 5g ça c'est cool on
a ce module de photos qui est décalé sur
le côté là qui est franchement très
sympa alors je pense qu'il vous le
verrez bien mais on devine l'aï écrit 64
mégapixels c'est donc ce que vous avez
sur votre capteur principal enlevant la
trois capteurs on y revient dans
quelques instants au niveau des capteurs
on venait la lumière des alors il se
déverrouille hop là directement là en
fait vous avez un petit bouton pour
venir le déverrouiller c'est un très
gros standards et en fait c'est un
bouton qui font office de capteur
d'empreintes digitales pour fait c'est
la même chose que vous allez retrouver
sur un modèle mais également sur l'autre
ça c'est le x4 gt mais vous l'avez
également sur hop là le f4 vous prenez
tac vous posez votre doigt vous
déverrouillez donc ça c'est plutôt cool
alors vous le voyez je pas si vous le
voyez d'ailleurs up la regarder j'ai
essayé de faire un peu plus attention
vous avez des petits points sont petits
points sont là et petits points sont là
on va se mettre comme ça pour vous le
voyez sur le f4 le point sont un peu
plus discret que sur le x4 gtc une
petite différence elles ont fait des
écrans qui sont différents en fait vous
avez d'un côté du lcd le côté cessé de
l'amoled mais je vais vous le détailler
dans quelques instants après vous avez
des bords qu'ils sont assez fort entre
zones hautement ça conviendra et puis
j'ai voulu dire tout de suite parce que
ce qui est important de savoir c'est les
tarifs pour bien venir les resituer
alors regardez les tailles sont hautes
et là j'ai ma petite feuille avec toutes
mes descriptions le x4 j'étais celui là
alors le gadget et on a deux versions
828 et coûte 300 lumière m'a lâché
379 euros et la version 8 256 coûte 429
euros je voulais disent extrêmement bien
placé vous allez voir par rapport aux
specs qu'on à l'intérieur c'est
extrêmement bien positionnée et y ait
des tarifs qui sont plus intéressants
mais je vous le détail à la fin de la
ville est donc resté bien évidemment
regarder cette vidéo jusqu'au nom et
puis vous avez celui là le poke au f4
alors lui coûte toujours les mêmes
conflits il ya eu 800 28 8 256 100 828
lui coûte 399 euros un petit peu au
dessus et puis vous avez version 8 256
qui coûte 4 149 euros ça ne tient à pas
grand chose à 20 euros près vous êtes
sensiblement au même tarif mais il ya
une petite différence pourquoi parce que
et pas la faute d'intérieur la boîte on
va regarder sur le scat j'étais alors
regardez moi ces risques at j'étais
j'aime bien le design est sympa et se
déroule bien très bonne prise en main
regarder on fait on le prend très
facilement une main on fait tout rejet
par les très grandes paluches mais ça va
très très bien on va retrouver sur le
dessus et bien une petite prise jack on
va retrouver de l'infrarouge également
s'intéressant aux haut-parleurs paris 6
haut-parleurs par-en-bas tiroirs de
cartes sim surcoté pas grand chose ici
et puis les boutons je voulais montrer
pour déverrouiller et oui donc ça c'est
un smartphone qui est très sympa en
termes de prise en main il est très cool
pareil sondés regarder le poke au f4
alors la différence que vous allez avoir
je peux si vous avez fait gaffe regardez
vous n'avez absolument aucune prise jack
ici rien à part vous avez néanmoins de
l'infrarouge alors vous allez retrouver
votre tiroir de cartes sim sur le bas
également le bouton pour déverrouiller
le bouton de volume de l'autre côté vous
n'avez absolument rien sinon en terme de
design c'est un super jolie smartphones
il ya des différences de couleurs le x4
j'étais vous l'avez soit noir soit en
gris soit en bleu tandis que le f4 vous
le retrouvez up pareil en trois couleurs
avec un dos qui est légèrement plus
brillants qui prendra un peu plus les
traces de doigts que leur qui est mat me
bros très sympa moi j'aime bien comme ça
je suis aussi très jolie les deux
coussins pas comme ça très honnêtement
lui on va la voir en gris en noir et en
verre comme ça il y en a pour tout le
monde à gré pour tous les goûts oui la
différence au niveau du module photo
c'est vraiment une question de goût
lequel vous préférez les redoublements
commentaires préféré lequel au niveau du
dos et au récent que le x4 j'étais un
peu plus bon mais que le f4 qui est
beaucoup plus plat gardez l'oeil
beaucoup plus plat l'huile est
légèrement bombée sur le côté d'un petit
peu plus de relief donc on a quand même
deux smartphones qui sont assez
différents au niveau au niveau du design
même si on retrouve les mêmes écriture
poko 5g d'un côté de l'autre après
chacun y trouvera son coup de coeur ce
qu'ils aiment en fonction de ses goûts
mais dans les deux cas les smartphones
sont très sympas on va reprendre sur
notre xk jet alors vous avez un écran
lcd cdu 6,61 pouces en full hd + 1
milliard de couleurs et surtout ce qui
est intéressant ici c'est que là vous
avez un taux de rafraîchissement
244 hertz 144 verte c'est quoi c'est le
nombre d'image que vous avez par seconde
en une seconde vous avez 144 image plus
vous avez d'image plus est fluide alors
plus vous avez d'image plusieurs bières
consommées au niveau de la batterie de
votre smartphone dell évidemment mais
vous avez pas du 144 heures en
permanence vous l'avez en fonction des
usages inventant des besoins que vous
avez donc ça c'est quand même plutôt pas
mal fichu regardez là vous l'avez soit
site soit vous le passez par défaut et
c'est recommandé il va gd façon
dynamique qu'il va choisir si le trou de
144 du 120 du 90 du 70 fera le job à
votre place soit vous venez de
personnaliser et vous le mettez comme
vous voulez bon très honnêtement je vous
recommande le mode par défaut qui est un
mode dynamique qui conviendra très bien
ça c'est vachement bien pourquoi le 144
esma pour les gamers si par exemple vous
allez jouer à différents jeux et que
vous voulez être le plus réactif
possible en terme d'affichage 144 r ça
ira très bien et en plus si vous avez un
taux d'échantillonnage tactile de 260
dire ce qui est très convenable pour
venir jouer à des jeux il ya aucun souci
la différence que vous allez retrouver
avec le f 4 life cactus et de l'amoled
on n'est pas sur un écran lcd ondées sur
un écran amoled on est sur du full hd
plus mais ici on n'a pas du 144 herses
on a dû 120 hertz alors il ya
effectivement une différence de 24
images par seconde que vous allez avoir
on aura un peu plus de fidélité sur le
x4 j'étais versus le f4 très honnêtement
entre 144 rc 120 hertz il ya une
différence mais si vous voulez de la
fluidité y avoir une très bonne
expérience de gaming sont le f4 il y
aura absolument aucun problème vous avez
en plus ici un écran certifié dernis
plus dolby vision vous avez à la
fonctionnalité truecolor donnera des
couleurs fidèles par rapport à ce que
vous ouvriez dont vous voyez donc quand
même mis le paquet en terme de
technologie pour vous avez un truc qui
fonctionne quand même vachement bien et
que vous en ayez pour votre argent et
souvenez-vous le tard il joue les
dictant ce smartphone là on est à 399 et
449 euros c'est très convenable aux
choses qui sont venus faire ils vous ont
mis des haut parleurs stéréo alors
regardez ces haut parleurs stéréo on
vient par là haut parleurs ici
haut-parleurs ici alors on s'en doutera
on n'est pas amis les quelques euros
donc on a un petit déséquilibre au
niveau de l'audio le haut parleur de
gauche mettra haut-parleurs de renfort
par rapport aux par l'endroit qui seront
pas leur principale mais ça fera le taf
si vous voulez venir augmenter
l'expérience vous prenez un casque en
bout tout ce que vous venez connecter à
l'un ou à l'autre en fonction du
smartphone que vous allez acheter et si
vous voulez acheter les deux bien vous
pouvez le faire vous avez le droit ça
vous regarde comme ça vous allez
maximiser l'expérience aux points qui
est aussi intéressant est vraiment de
différenciation entre les deux et bien
c'est le choix qui a été fait en termes
de processeurs en termes de performances
quoi parce que sur le x4 gt on a un
processeur de médiathèque c'est le
dimettiti 8100 qui est un processeur 5 g
tandis que sur le f4 vous êtes chez
qualcomm vous avez à sa dragonne 870 5g
pour essayer de resituer un peu tout ça
on va commencer par le x4 gt se dit man
city 8000 sont 5 g c'est un équivalent
de ce qu'on va retrouver dans le plus
haut de gamme chez qualcomm c'est un
équivalent et c'est surtout un des
processeurs les plus haut de gamme ici
de chez mediatek ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que c'est un processeur qui va
totalement optimisé pour vous apporter
de la fluidité lorsque vous allez venir
jouer à vos jeux pas de compromis de la
fluidité et une bonne gestion de
l'autonomie c'est vraiment l'idée de ce
qu'on sait soir vous allez retrouver ici
donc pour venir jouer pour jouer à plein
de jeux pour maximiser l'expérience vous
avez un smartphone qui rateraient bien
de l'autre côté ils sont dit ok on va
aller chez qualcomm on a un processeur
de la série 8 alors je vous la fais très
très court vous avez plusieurs séries et
chez qualcomm et la série 8 c'est la
série très haut de gamme le 1 877 un
processeur qui est sorti l'année
dernière la même année que le 888 on est
un poil moins performant que le 888 mais
on est toujours très performant parce
que dans un processeur très haut de
gamme et ça c'est vachement chouette par
l'aïe de la même manière des
performances très bonne gestion de
l'autonomie et puis un smartphone qui ne
vous lâchera pas que vous avez bien
jouer à tous les jeux vous voulez donc
sans aucun problème donc ça aussi c'est
chouette donc pour vous vouliez prendre
l'un ou l'autre pour du gaming vous
n'aurai absolument aucun problème est
d'autant plus que sur laon et sur la
technologie liquid cooled 2.0 où vous
avez une grande chambre à vapeur plus
différentes couches de grafite qui vont
être là pour venir dissiper la chaleur
de votre smartphone pour éviter qu il ne
chauffe trop haute différences
importantes entre les deux est bien ça
va être la batterie sur le x4 gt on a
une grosse batterie de 5080 milliampères
heures avec un bloc de charge de 67,3
alors que vous soyez sur l'un ou sur
l'autre vous avez dû 67 67 soit regardée
sur l'un et sur l'autre j'ai également
dû 67 toi ça veut dire quoi ça eh bien
ça veut dire que ça vient vous de
recharger rapidement je vous ai pas lire
sur le f4 animatrice de 4500 millions
paiera donc on a quand même une
différence au niveau de la batterie
chant ces deux smartphones la plus
grosse batterie savez du goûter du x 4 g
t on en batterie un peu moins gros sur
le f 4 mais très honnêtement un peu plus
de 5000 méliand perreur versus 4500
milan perd heures ça conviendra bien
vous pouvez monter jusqu'à aller un jour
et demi deux jours d'autonomie ça va
dépendre une fois de plus de vous de vos
usages est ce que vous allez passer tout
en 144 ailleurs tout est le cas vous
avez consommé davantage est-ce que vous
allez beaucoup joué si vous jouez
beaucoup bel évidemment bien vous venez
vous rechargez et puisqu'ils écoulé ce
qui est rassurant et ça je vous dis
souvent dans mes vidéos c'est que
lorsque vous avez un blog changes rapide
comme ça comme du 67e watts par exemple
et bien vont venir charger votre
smartphone rapidement deux roues bien
moins se prend la tête sur la question
de l'autonomie de son smartphone vous
rechargez par exemple x4 gt20 à 100% 46
minutes tandis que le f4 vous de
recharge et de 0 à 100% en 38 minutes
selon vous dire que ça va ça va vite
alors là je vous parle de 0 à 100% mais
je voulais déjà dit également un
smartphone leurs charges et pas
nécessairement à 100% vous leurs charges
et entre 20 et 80 % et tout au début de
lâchage c'est là où savalli plus vite
notamment grâce à une charge 60 7 watts
donc en un petit quart d'heure vous êtes
reparti pour un jour d'autonomie sans
problème donc ça c'est aussi très
rassurant donc on voit qu'on a de la
performance qu'on a ce qu'il faut sous
le capot en termes de batteries pour
l'autonomie pour aller loin on va qu'on
leur charge rapidement bref on est sur
des smartphones cool mais il ya un autre
truc a été fait qui est intéressant
c'est qu'on va retrouver au niveau de la
photo alors regardez vous avez le même
nombre de mégapixels que ce soit sur un
smartphone ou sur l'autre là je vais
avoir un capteur grand-angle de 64
mégapixels un ultra grand angle de 8
mégapixels et puis genre de la macro de
16 mégapixels c'est pareil d'un côté
l'autre ils ont fait la même
configuration pour que vous puissiez
faire sensiblement la même chose en
terme de photos si vous souhaitez si ça
vous intéresse tout en sachant que et ça
c'est aussi un truc qui est assez
intéressant là des jeux vous montrez
vous venez dans votre logiciel ici là
pour venir a ajouté vous mettez en vidéo
et tac voulez là et vous pouvez venir
filmer regarder ses marques et ici en
noir sur blanc jusqu'en capca à 30
images par seconde et même bien filmé en
macro si vous le souhaitez alors vous
passez ce moment là en 720p en paria
phare de la macro en 1080p est ce qu'on
a réellement besoin de venir filmer en
macro très honnêtement je suis pas
convaincu mais si vous voulez pouvait le
faire et puis après vous avez plein de
modes à parce que façon tourner ici sur
me why try donc l'expérience logiciel va
être la même que ce soit sur la route
sur l'autre vous avez plein de trucs un
plein de modes différents un mode pro
pour revenir à shooter comme vous voulez
si vous voulez rester en 64 mégapixels
tout le temps pourrait le faire sinon
vous allez avoir une technologie clé du
pixel baning ces derniers regroupés 4
pixels en un seul et même leurs pixels
pour vous sortir une photo complètement
optimisé d'un point de vue logiciel donc
ça c'est cool vous avez un mode
documents pourraient venir se caler des
documents toussa toussa toussa si vous
le souhaitez ça c'est plutôt aussi pas
mal le mode vidéo je voulais montrer
vous avez le mode photo un mode portrait
également qu'on peut venir faire un
bonne nuit et puis après il ya plein de
modes en plus vidéo cours panorama mode
qu'on avait déjà vu il ya quelques
années j'avais déjà montré clown basé
sur l'exposition longue donc on a pas
mal de possibilités d'un point de vue
logiciel donc si vous êtes créatif et
vous voulez bien vous amuser que ses
smartphones vous avez aussi de quoi
faire d'un point de vue logiciel il ya
pas mal de choses tout en sachant qu'ici
effectivement le meilleur capteur sera
le 404 mégapixels mais ça on s'en doute
il ya des trucs à savoir au niveau de la
photo qui est vachement intéressant
c'est que vous avez une différence qui
est assez significative entre les deux
si vous voulez un smartphone qui ira
plus loin au niveau de la photo ça sera
le f4 et je vais vous expliquer pourquoi
dans quelques instants mais avec le x4
j'étais comme je voulais montrer vous
avez la même config mais il ya quand
même un petit point de différence ça
c'est les photos qui sont réalisés avec
le x4 j'étais j'ai fait quelques photos
pour venir vous montrer alors dans
l'ensemble mais s'en sort pas trop mal
sur le capteur principal on voit qu'il
est un peu plus de mal au niveau des
hautes lumières ici vous dire qu'il ya
un soleil de plomb que ça tape fort où
on va c'est pas trop son truc il va un
peu plus souffrir une fois de plus c'est
pas un photophone poko est vraiment
accès au niveau de la performance brute
et de la puissance on peut venir faire
des photos avec mais ça sera pas le
meilleur photophone dans cette gamme de
prix là on peut passer ensuite sur
l'ultra grand-angle que vous avez là un
peu moins précis mais c'est un ultra
grand-angle et ce n'est pas surprenant
vu le prix où on est on peut venir
soumet un petit peu mais on va venir
éviter je vous montre un petit peu ici
là on est quasiment en voyant le soleil
qui est juste là mais pour autant le taf
effet c'est convenable c'est correct
vous pour venir choper des souvenirs on
arrivera à faire des choses comme ça
c'est un peu ce qu'on peut venir faire
ici avec votre x4 j'étais le f4 il a un
avantage qui est autre c'est à dire que
il a une stabilisation optique au niveau
du capteur principal l'appel de l'eau y
est ce une image qui est complètement
stabilisée d'un point de vue optique et
ça c'est plutôt bien pourquoi parce que
si vous bouger un petit peu aussi pesé
dans des conditions où ça bouge un peu
vous êtes comme moi qu'un tremblement
essentiel eh bien ça ne bougera pas et
ça c'est plutôt pas mal se parler sortir
de meilleures photos pourtant on
retrouvera un peu le même profil de
photos que ce qu'on va retrouver sur le
x4 j'étais à savoir que sur les hautes
lumières il avoir un peu plus de mal
mais dans l'ensemble ça ira très bien
pour me refaire des souvenirs ça
fonctionnera ultra-grand-angle même
reproche un peu moins précis on peut
venir nous un peu mais on vient éviter
parce qu'on est tous sur du numérique
mais regardez sauf que dans l'ensemble
c'est pas mal on a le soleil là s'en
sortent plutôt pas trop mal donc ça
c'est vraiment intéressant l'ultra grand
temps bof on passe très très rapidement
mais sinon sans vote grand-angle le taf
effet ça c'est plutôt cool donc
cette différence à venir voir si vous
voulez plus de la photo qui sera un peu
plus stabilisé et un peu meilleur on va
venir aller ici sur le f 4 mai le xk
s'en sort également pas trop mal mais il
faut pas que ça bouge du tout ça c'est
un point une différenciation il faut
aussi le connaître tout en sachant et ce
qui est intéressant ici c'est que alors
vous avez gagné évidemment du nfc pour
le paiement dématérialisé avec ses
smartphones et puis un truc qui est
intéressant c'est qu'en fait et je vous
disais tout à l'heure en fait peau qu
ils ne font aucun compromis au niveau de
la performance c'est vraiment leur adn
ils veulent des smartphones extrêmement
performant c'est la raison pour laquelle
vous allez venir vous retrouvez avec les
meilleures technologies qu'on puisse
imaginer aujourd'hui c'est à dire où la
ram c'est du fsrs trois points et au
niveau de roms au niveau du stockage ces
deux là il peut déduire 50 ans vous dire
que ça ira très très bien deux
smartphones que vous pouvez venir
acheter si vous intéresse alors pas
forcément les deux mais un des deux à
venir voir lequel qui vous intéresse il
ya vraiment deux écoles différentes sur
le x4 ce qui va vraiment me retenir ici
je dirais au point de différenciation
sec sur le poteau le x4 gt et bien vous
allez avoir un écran lcd vous allez pas
avoir comme sur le f 4 il ya un écran
amoled les contraste infini des noirs
très profonds ça sera un peu différent
n'ira pas aussi loin au niveau de
l'écran néanmoins vous aurez un taux de
rafraîchissement de 144 r donc si vous
l'aviez repoussé games et vous avez un
tout ira très bien avec un plus grosse
batterie et puis le dimettiti 8105 jet
qui fonctionnera bien de l'autre côté si
vous voulez maximiser l'expérience je
dirais de visionnage avoir un écran où
vous allez voir c'est noir infinie grâce
à un écran amoled et bien c'est plus le
pot coeff cas très honnêtement ces deux
smartphones ont de très belle fiche
technique d'un côté et de l'autre il ya
des petits points de différenciation au
niveau des processeurs ça est
extrêmement minime maintenant à vous de
voir si vous voulez un écran amoled oui
ou pas ou si vous préférez un écran lcd
est ce que vous voulez pousser au
maximum l'expérience de gaming avec le
plus haut taux de rafraîchissement avec
celui lançant t'es rock à travers ce
versus celui là qui vous proposera du
sens inverse mais qui a également très
bien et puis une fois de plus notre truc
qui vient différencier ce design vous
préférez lequel celui là avec le dôme à
tous alors le f4 à claude briand à vous
de voir dites moi ce que vous en pensez
et tout en sachant qu'ils ont c'est une
petite différence au niveau du poinçon
vous allez venir retrouver où
effectivement sur le f4 il sera un poil
plus discret mais je dis bien en pour
elle peu discret là je voulais montrer
l'un à côté de l'autre mais si vous en
voyez qu'un seul vous le verrez dans
l'eau lui ça ira très bien beaucoup de
coeur à moi il se fait au niveau du x4
j'étais parce que bien que n'ayant pas
un écran amoled et bien j'adore le
design j'aime bien ce petit de maths
c'est très cool d'avoir cet autre
affaissement 244 yards se trouve très
intéressant il est un peu moins chères
classe alors et des tarifs qui sont
super intéressant tout de suite aller
jeter un coup d'oeil directement sur le
site de poko fournit tous les liens en
bas dans la description sur le x4
j'étais je vous le dis vous avez du 4
juillet à 13h au 9 juillet à 13h c'est
très très près si vous avez des offres
spéciales au lieu d'avoir la version 828
à 379 vous l'avez à 299 et la version 8
256 wade d'avoir à 429 vous l'avez à 349
c'est quand même vachement plus
intéressant c'est hyper canon donc je
vous invite à les découvrir si ces
smartphones vous intéresse vous mais
tous les liens en bas dans la
description une fois de plus poco a
vraiment mis le paquet au niveau de la
performance vraiment là où ils sont les
meilleurs super expérience tarifs hyper
canon très grosse performance pour game
et pour me regarder des films des séries
pour se faire plaisir vous avez de très
jolis smartphone à vous oui vous de me
dire ce que vous en pensez maintenant on
va aux commentaires et ce qu'il vous
temps qu'il vous plaise il vous botte il
vous arrive vous voulez voudriez ou
alors absolument pas marquer moi ça en
bas en commentaire non on se retrouve
très vite pour faire quoi pour parler de
tels gains évidemment on d'ici là
premier truc vous de vous et bien
évidemment je vous embrasse broker sur
vous débit d'eau et beaucoup d'amour à
bientôt
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]